our next award goes to one of the
beloved people of this town and one of
the founders of the Academy in his early
days he made pictures in the east but 30
years ago we came out here with only
three stars to his name
Norman Constance Tallmadge and Buster
Keaton
he built a great company around them
later reformed other companies United
Artists for one 20th century then 20th
Century Fox and all along the line he
was generous generous with his money
generous with his friendship and
generous with his wisdom his wisdom we
have come to rely someone has called him
the Barney booth of the industry perhaps
that is as good a description as any of
Joseph M skink
mr. skank is all route to New York and
he asked has asked one of his friends to
accept for him miss Gloria Swanson
dear Gloria would you please convey to
the Academy and the Board of Governors
my sincere gratitude for the award
it has conferred upon me it is an honor
I never dreamed I would ever receive
when I helped to form the Academy 25
years ago I am deeply moved
San Jose
our next honorary award goes to one of
the longtime innovators of the industry
who began by making the first
full-length documentary and one of the
best it was called grass his next with
Chang about elephants and in that one
the screen widened out at a certain
point he made the first science-fantasy
that was King Kong he became interested
in a new film process Technicolor threw
him Technicolor came into practical use
a few years ago that knows for novelty
started twitching again and suddenly
there was a film called this is Cinerama
playing on Broadway the ripples from it
have come this way they have generated
quite a stir in our wonderful medium in
honor of all his innovations the board
has voted an honorary award to Marion
see
I just heard what was said it isn't
strictly accurate by any means I'm a
man's just had a been lucky on having a
wonderful partners schoedsack really did
LACMA was knighted on grass and chain
and right down the line I only had John
Ford as a partner whoever calamus is a
great friend in Technicolor and for
Cinerama my fred wahl invented it
Laurel Thomas picked up the ball and ran
with it
and there's a young man in this audience
Bob Bendix no sir you never heard out
that did farm or the production I did I
want to thank all the great partners
have had my life thank you
I just want all I'm still John Ford's
partner